hello guys I'm Ryan right right now I'm
in New Jersey
visiting family I want to give a shout
out to my grandma real fast
she is one of the most loving
grandmother's you can ever meet I rarely
got to see her and she is a beautiful
beautiful woman always made me feel good
for the phone you're gonna be on the
news one day you're gonna be on the news
one day you have such a beautiful voice
it should always tell me so yeah
just want to say hi grandma we're going
to New York a lot it's been fun and
speaking of New York someone's back in
the Big Apple
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles part
dos all right so this is called out of
the shadows Megan Fox returns I heard
they got a new director I wasn't the
biggest fan of the first one I rewatched
it again on Netflix and I thought it was
actually like a lot of fun the second
time I watched it I realized I'm
probably took this too seriously the
first time I watched it for like a kid's
movie it's pretty [ __ ] fun let's see
how this one looks
[Music]
what's happening out there Donnie I
don't know Wow
Europe God Michael Bay was involved in
producing this film
[Music]
[Music]
what are you just four brothers who
hates bullies
heylia
Casey oh [ __ ] toy gun actors nuclear but
we could work with that me too
oh yes y'all got jokes huh
[Music]
she's so hot
yeah it looks good whoa
I
[ __ ]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] no it's cool that looks better
than the first one already the day a
Ninja Turtles trailer is better than the
Batman V Superman trailer I wonder how
many dislikes I just got this video by
saying that first off as far as a
trailer goes it's doing a great job
because the film looks like a blast
it looks like just a ton of fun you know
my problem with the first film when I
when I first watched it was I thought it
took itself too seriously like I felt
there was a lot of unintentional
laughter of me yeah there's a lot of
intentional laughter - I felt a lot of
it was like this is cheesy when they
want to be taken seriously first parts
of the trailer I was like this looks
like Michael they directed it I know he
didn't die no he just produces it but
still it was like did they get the same
DP or something but as the trailer
progressed I was like you know what this
this is shot better like there's things
about the trailer that I really like
there's things about I he was still
unsure about for example Tyler Perry I
feel like this film might have a more
comedic vibe to it which I'm really
hoping they do I out but they're not
trying to be all dark tone about it cuz
it's a sequel I want this one to be more
fun and I feel like Tyler Perry the
brief portrayal we got of his characters
Baxter Stockman or something he's seems
very cartoony he looks like if Steve
Urkel went evil however that character
might not have worked for the first
Ninja Turtles cuz I know he was only
like briefly mentioned in it and this
one would the way the tone is looking
like it's coming across I feel like he
could work I mean he even got bebop and
Rocksteady in here and they're like
goofy villains you know like if you ever
watch the cartoons I didn't read the
comics i watch the cartoons growing up
and they're pretty silly villains but
they seem like they got the attitude of
the characters down i like the motion
capture of the characters i think
everything looks more finely tuned I
felt like the lighting with the CGI of
the turtles and bebop and Rocksteady I
felt looked really good like I felt like
a match more because in the first one I
see the cgi outline way too much oh and
I love that when the turtles come on the
street that they're in the [ __ ]
turtle van dude that was so [ __ ] cool
the turtle van has been something I've
wanted in the movies the live-action
ones of course because the turtle van is
the turtle van
you can't have the teenage beat as I
know the first three live-action ones I
don't think they had a turtle van
in any of them I'm not sure actually
don't quote me on that and I love seeing
the [ __ ] Steven know oh I think is
his name uh one should really do more
research before filming a trailer
reaction Stephen Amell I love him as air
oh man he is perfect and in that
character I'm not fully caught up on
arrow so don't you know give [ __ ] away
but he is perfect he knows how to bring
that perfect level of coolness
confidence but also a great sense of
humor and swag eases it's a sexy [ __ ]
guy what can I say he's built - he's
beautiful beautiful Tyrone Magnus and
him to make love and Casey is the [ __ ] I
know a guy named Casey in real life
you're the [ __ ] - the Casey Jones man I
even liked him in the first Ninja
Turtles the live-action one I feel like
this is a different portrayal he doesn't
look as dirty but it's the dude who
plays Green Arrow come on man and hold
on let me rewind this real fast where is
it I want to make sure so now you
[ __ ] are whenever I get something
like slightly I could say like a million
things right but if I get one thing
wrong all you guys like tear me a new
one like nothing of what I said that was
right counts [ __ ] where is it okay
yeah shredder shredder is here shredder
is a human being that is a major I feel
like the filmmakers of this one heard a
lot of what the [ __ ] talk was about the
first movie and they actually listened
to the advice granted just the trailer
could be just a great trailer however if
this trailer is portraying the movie
well this could be a much better
improvement
I know this one I'm still gonna get a
lot of crap from the fact that there are
things in it that do look like they're
out of a Michael Bay film especially all
the explosions and [ __ ] I'm okay with
that I feel like I can move past that
even the stuff in the first Ninja
Turtles I was able to move past the
Michael Bay reminiscence [ __ ] this one I
feel like it won't be that much of a
distraction get over it guys sorry he
produced it okay he didn't direct it he
produced it so they go and looking back
at this trailer there's a scene right
here where the turtles are out in the
open and that's kind of weird to me
because what I thought the turtles were
like enjoy didn't think they were gonna
be out of broad daylight being like hey
where are the Turtles
doesn't seem Ninja Turtle like I feel
like I probably be able to move past it
but there's a part of me though that's
like that's a big thing about their
characters though is that you know they
travel in the night all that [ __ ] that
they learned from splinter they traveled
in at night they were hidden they
they're not supposed to be out there I
know a lot people are gonna be like oh
well you know it's being more realistic
and you really keep these giant turtles
hidden yeah you don't have to worry
about realism when it comes to this
[ __ ] movie and I guess I should
comment on Megan Fox Megan Fox is back
and she was never really a great actress
but she's she's always interesting for
me to watch cuz yes a she is pretty B I
feel like she thinks she's doing a good
job when she's doing this like I know I
can't tell if she's like I'm just phone
in this and I'm just caching this and I
don't need to be great or if she's
actually it's like a young Channing
Tatum like proceed with confidence even
though you're not doing a good job
I feel like Taylor Lautner is finally
breaking out of that just to start
insulting some actors on the side that's
what I wanted to do anyway guys thanks
for tuning in to the channel listen if
you're new to it subscribe today become
a reject yeah that's a cool thing to
name you guys and follow us on our
social networks I'm now on the you-now
app it's a free app so don't [ __ ] about
it it's a free app and you could do live
streams on there I think it's more fun
than periscope so follow me on there
real Ryan right actually I want to end
this video on a thank you note I had to
come out here for more than just a trip
it's been a rather emotional week and
it's been a lot of great fun got to meet
Tyrone Magnus I got to see like most of
New York already and so there's been a
lot of beautiful things here and even
like the [ __ ] I'm going through it's
kind of beautiful in some way but you
know I'm pretty tired I know I've been
delayed on like uploading videos and
stuff so I want to apologize for that
but thank you guys because this is like
one of my favorite things to do really
helps me get my mind off things and it
feels good to do it so thank you
okay I wanna April the new bumps into
it's a Michelangelo and then and then
April's like hey that was a really rock
hard shell and then Michelangelo turns
around and goes that was in my shell
comedy